let me just get in the moment lock eyes
with you and then really just retain you
know what i mean and really be here for
that yeah i'll save the the
the cheaper compliments for the end but
okay it meant so much to me for you to
just pull your dick out and your [ __ ]
out because we were nervous and now i
feel so much more at ease and i feel so
much more connected to you
after you pulled all that out so thank
you
for flashing [ __ ] and b-hole cause it
really did make me feel
just safe so thank you okay and you do
have a beautiful butthole like your
butthole is really nice man
it's not a lot of hair there's none it's
a miracle it's incredible any poo
residue no it had like a nice coloration
to it it was really lovely dude deep a
day
a dupa day mm-hmm every day today but
now
now i wear this movie this podcast is
like the movie flight where like the
most incredible scene in it happens
right at the beginning
downhill yeah after that you're like
well how are they gonna do the plane
crash yeah yeah yeah we already got the
plane crash yeah but sometimes you know
we'll have to close strong
right we'll have to yeah i know what
that means yeah no no we'll have to you
know what we'll have to do a shyamalan
twist oh right
right and we'll figure that out at the
end you know it'll pop sometimes it
feels like when you're watching a
shyamalan movie you don't even know that
he knows what's going on until the end
right right and i feel like he shoots it
and he's like
he wakes up this is how i'm gonna end it
today yeah he doesn't know he doesn't
even know at the end it might have been
my behold the whole time
oh [ __ ] that's a great switch yeah yeah
yeah wow yeah yeah um
it's a really good one um i bet i bet
our buttholes
i don't like to talk about this stuff
because you know i'm becoming more
religious and more christian i'm getting
more prudish too yeah as i get older so
you know i mean it makes me feel
uncomfortable talking about stuff like
this but since we're here
i feel like you know you and i jt
you know if we compared buttholes you
mean and we showed it to just random
people you know people coming from a
different country imagine there's a
little room at lax the international
right and it brings them into this room
foreigners and they compared to our
buttholes they would go yes they're from
the same
family
right i hope so right but if they showed
yours and mine they're definitely
defense
family
do you think or no
i think so i mean we've we kind of yeah
i guess so
hard to tell what do you mean i wish my
butthole looked like yours yeah why do
you think yours would compare to his
more than yeah because i'm hairy i know
but you have more of an olivey vibe to
you oh i've always said you're like more
of a billy joel and you're more like you
know um
the guy from the eagles
oh don henry not henley yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah don henley be all you're more like
billy joel b hall you have sort of
yeah yeah
don't you think yeah yeah you know i
think i've just i've always been
disappointed in mine if i'm completely
candid why what about it i don't know i
think um
i think it just i think i don't have
i think it just doesn't really shine
i feel the same way about mine really
yeah i think mine is so
heartbreakingly mediocre right
yeah it doesn't have it doesn't stand
out like his it's got a very like
there's some
sparse hair growth that i often wax out
right but can i say something yeah
it doesn't shine
but yeah your vag is fantastic
so it's like when you write so when you
compare
when you compare the two you're mean and
what's the most important that's nice
right right what's the most important
you know and with yours i've never seen
it i'm just making working with
assumptions okay that if you bent over i
would like oh that's don henley's
butthole pass but when i saw that
right yeah pass on that right i would
pass on that right but if i saw your sex
right oh yeah i'd be like that's
you know what i mean
tom hardy's zach
are you for real right now
yeah
i i'll even take it i'll take it a step
further further
oh look at the butthole don hundley pass
right
sex
so
yeah and that that comes from my heart
and that's belief
and truism okay so how do you feel
bobby i just want to say
i owe you a 10 second car
it's a car that goes a quarter mile in
under 10 seconds
that was like what paul owed to oh
wait have you never seen passengers i've
never seen any of those movies i've
never seen anything totally ruined the
moment
it threw me off
but you don't want to
that's a lesson to be learned for me
right yeah but can i say this even
without watching those movies i i
understand his greatness and that's the
power of paul walker yeah right
excuse me he's inspirational